let me introduce uh professor bonay it's
my pleasure to introduce him he's a he
heads the applied cryptography group
here uh at stanford he also co-directs
the computer security lab his research
focuses on the applications of
cryptography to computer security and
he's not just uh you know a researcher
he's also a very innovative educator he
is the co-director of stanford's
advanced cyber security professional
program which is an online self-paced
program as well as our online
cybersecurity graduate program which is
taking on campus graduate classes and
making them available to remote learners
he also has a mooc on cryptography and
he has co-written a free online textbook
on applied cryptography so if you like
what you see here uh there are a lot
more places to to hear dan talk and i
should say he's done quite a few
webinars uh with us and so there there's
a webinar on the same topic from about
three years ago interesting to see side
by side what has changed as well as on
other topics so with that then i'm going
to hand the reins over to you
so i'm not sure what everybody's
backgrounds are and so i thought you
know this would be more of a kind of a
high level talk about what's happening
in the blockchain space as i said if you
want to kind of get into more details um
feel free to sign up to any of our
classes and that's where we get into a
lot more detail than i have time for
here but let's start from zero let's
start at the beginning and then we'll go
we'll go uh deeper so what is a
blockchain so to me the abstract answer
for what a blockchain provides is
basically kind of it provides
coordination yeah it's a way to
basically uh for many distrusting
parties to coordinate with one another
without a single trusted party yeah so
in financial applications we can
coordinate and uh run a financial
financial system even though we don't
trust one another
and there as we see in just a minute
there are many other areas where
blockchains apply
one thing that i want to caution
everybody is that uh because the
blockchain area seems to be like a
pretty popular area there's a a lot of
i've seen a lot of attempts to sort of
use blockchains in environments where
they're not the best solution
so what i want you to keep in mind
is really that if any environment that
already already has a trusted party
that all the participants actually are
happy to trust with their data in that
case there's no need for a blockchain
right right in that case there are many
centralized systems that are much
simpler and cheaper to run so you might
as well use use one of those yeah so
this is kind of an important thing to
remember i mean i've seen people try to
use blockchains in environments you know
where maybe there are easier solutions
so um you know let's focus on
on on applications of blockchains where
they really do make sense and of course
in a financial system there's usually
not a trusted party nobody trusts anyone
in finance and so that's actually where
blockchains kind of shine
so again just sticking with a high level
for just a little bit so in my mind the
blockchain is sort of made up of four
different components i used to call them
layers but layers of the word layer is
used for something else in the world of
blockchain so i'll just call them
components yeah so there's a consensus
component this is just to make sure it's
like a ground layer just to make sure
everybody's agreeing on all the data
that's on the blockchain yeah so it's
not possible that one person sees uh one
uh set of transactions on the chain and
another person sees another set of
transaction launching and that property
should hold for all but the very last
set of transactions
they were that were added to the chain
so there's consensus and that we all
agree on what is on the blockchain and
also the blockchain has to be live in
the sense that anyone can always add
more transactions to the chain
so there's a lot to say about consensus
that's not what i wanted to talk about
today uh so we'll move on above
consensus uh sits with what i call the
compute layer sometimes this is called a
blockchain computer and this is
basically a virtual machine on which on
top of which people can run applications
yeah once we have a consensus layer
where everybody agrees on what the data
is we can start talking about
computations on top of this data yeah
and the way to do that is using the
blockchain computer which is what i
would call the compute component or
compute layer typically these together
uh form the core of a blockchain right
if you think of ethereum there's a
consensus component and there's a
compute component namely the evm if you
think of bitcoin there's a consensus
component and then there's a bit of a
primitive compute component that is the
bitcoin scripting language and the same
is true for many other for many other
blockchains once we have these two
components consensus and compute we can
start writing applications on top of the
blockchain computer those are called
decentralized applications or dapps and
they can do a whole bunch of different
things as we'll see in just a minute
and finally the last component is
basically the component that interacts
with the actual user so uh these are
typically systems that run in the cloud
just a regular cloud they take
instructions commands from the end user
and they communicate those commands to
the to the dap and vice versa yeah so
those are to me those are kind of the
four components that make up a
blockchain and there's a lot of activity
happening in all four it's really such
an active area that i can tell you also
as pax said um we've been running this
this blockchain program now for a while
i can tell you the teaching of
blockchain class is one of the hardest
things in the world because literally
the entire class has to change from year
to year it's very different from
teaching calculus where you're teaching
the same thing over and over there's so
much activity in the blockchain space
that we kind of have to redo the class
almost from scratch every year it's
really quite quite remarkable and it's
actually what makes it so much fun to
teach
um
maybe i'll go through this quickly just
i wanted to show you one one more time
kind of the picture of how these how
these blockchain applications are built
right so they're all built on top of the
consensus layer there is all these
applications uh the dapps running inside
of a block on top of a blockchain
computer they all have they all maintain
states that's on that store and on the
blockchain for example uh what is
everybody's balances right that's state
that's maintained on top of the
blockchain and then the end user
actually interacts with these cloud
servers the cloud servers themselves
have a database that replicates often
the data that's stored on the chain and
then these servers are the ones that
actually interact with the block with
the blockchain itself of course if the
user wanted to the user could interact
directly with the blockchain that's done
through you know there are many uh end
user type
programs that will interact directly
with a blockchain without going through
a cloud service um
but typically there will be some sort of
a cloud service that presents
information to users and that's the
thing that interacts with the team so
this is kind of at a high level how
these systems operate and so now we can
kind of start with um with what i wanted
to talk about so first of all i wanted
to kind of make sure everybody is kind
of aware of all the application domains
where blockchains have been used so far
so primarily they started with financial
applications because again that's an
environment where nobody trusts but
typically there's no trusted party so
defy applications make a lot of sense
for blockchains but over the years we've
seen them we've actually come up with a
couple of other
areas where blockchains are a very good
fit
so one of them are what are called nfts
or you know non-fungible assets so
things like arts sports cards uh things
like that and there you know there are
um
services like nba topshop where you can
buy
uh or you can own videos of your
favorite athletes openc where you can
buy art foundation where you can buy art
and so on and again the exercise you
always have to go through is ask
yourself why is it that we want to
record art ownership on the blockchain
why can't we just use a centralized
system that says who owns what and the
answer actually is quite simple you know
if we had a centralized system that
recorded who owns what art
if that for some reason if that
centralized system either got hacked or
it got corrupt corrupted or maybe just
went out of business
and the database disappeared the
ownership information would kind of be
gone with it yeah and so storing
ownership information
that has to live for you know
potentially you know decades or maybe
even centuries like ownership of art
which might you know propagate through
generations we want to make sure that
that's stored in an area they can know
in a system that can never go out of
business and and basically die and a
blockchain
is a wonderful way to do this my
personal belief is the blockchains we're
building today are going to be with us
forever now yeah so information that we
put on ethereum information we put on
the bitcoin blockchain it's likely well
i'll support ethereum more for that but
um most likely the information we put
there will stay with humanity now for
decades if not centuries and so in that
sense this is a very good match as an
application because we can record
ownership of those things long-term
things and
basically ownership cannot change unless
the owner of the piece of art
decides to give it away
it turns out we've seen other domains
where this this type of property is
useful too for example in gaming right
there are a number of games now that are
being played on blockchains and again
gaming assets in some sense follow the
same rules as art um in that you know if
i own a particular uh you know sword and
a game or if i own a particular skin in
a game i want to record that that is
that i am the owner of that and no one
should be able to take it away from me
unless i give permission so again it
makes
a lot of sense to store gaming
information on the blockchain as well
we're actually seeing a lot of that and
then moreover we're actually seeing
gains being played on a blockchain and
again all the revenue and benefits and
assets that are being generated by
generated by the game are all reported
on the blockchain
so that information will stay there
forever and cannot be changed without
the owner's consent and the fourth area
that i wanted to mention which is again
very exciting i think um is the area of
decentralized organizations what are
called daos decentralized autonomous
organizations um and so as you know
these dials are basically used for
investment so you know a group of people
can get together establish a dow
everybody contributes funds to the dao
and then the community as a whole makes
investment decisions right so this is
kind of a modern uh investor investment
bank where the community decides how to
invest the um
the the assets uh stored in the dao and
uh that actually there are a couple of
very large dials that are quite
successful in doing that there are
doubts for donations for charity there
are doubts for collecting art like
pleasure dao pleaser dao is a
well-known dao for collecting art and uh
and so on what's interesting is it's
actually quite easy to create dao's
there are many tools out there that will
let you create a dial with whatever
rules you want uh syndicate is one
example but there are many other tools
out there that will let you uh let you
create and manage dials so this is
something that you can literally go out
this afternoon and play with go ahead
and create a dao invite your friends to
join it
and if you have a cool idea for what you
guys want to do together you can all
that could all be done through uh
governance process
that you and your community kind of uh
does that's together so lots of
successful dials out there today and
this is another area where blockchains
really kind of shine
okay so those are kind of the current
application domains where blockchains
are used i hope there'll be more in the
future yeah the more the better uh but
these four are kind of right now where
much of the accent action takes place
i guess i quickly want to just remind
people in the d5 space
um again i imagine many of the people
who are watching know this so maybe i
can go through this very quickly but in
the d5 space there are a lot of
experiments going on
um yes so just to point call out a few
compound is a very successful lending
platform um i guess uniswap is a very
successful exchange online exchange that
allows you to change one asset for
another all being done on uh on the
blockchain um uh you know there are
custodial services for managing your
assets and finally i'll mention
stablecoins which is again a beautiful
beautiful idea so here i'm just pointing
to maker dao particularly their coin die
uh which is just a beautiful idea of how
do you run um how do you build a stable
coin on top of an unstable asset and
there's a lot of science that goes into
this um
which is again something that we talk
about at length uh in the class so uh
yeah this is again just beautiful set of
ideas i wish i had more time to talk
about that but i want to talk about
other things in the time that we have
together
and the other thing is that there's a
large number of number of experiments
going on you know this is just from d5
pulse a lot the largest projects that
have the most block value in them if we
step back a second um and just reflect
on what's happened in the last 12 years
since uh satoshi launched bitcoin it's
really quite remarkable i mean it's it's
really amazing if you look at the
numbers the amount of money that these
um programs are managing literally these
are like if you think about these these
are like 600 line programs that are
managing you know tens uh 10 billion
dollars
um i think it's a it's an incredible
success for the community it's it's
really uh quite beautiful that uh that
this has happened but again it's
literally 600 lines of code any and the
code is open source anyone can look at
this code and and um study how it
behaves in fact the way i learn about
about a project is typically by looking
at the actual code that runs the project
and it's really quite remarkable this
this code is not very complicated uh
it's not very very long
and uh the whole point is actually to
keep it simple so that we can actually
uh get some confidence that it's
properly managing the treasury that it's
being that's in charge of managing but
really that's what's happening here
right it means relatively short programs
are managing uh enormous amounts of
assets so quite impressive that this has
happened
okay so um i guess again there was a
couple of topics that i wanted to talk
about but before we get to those topics
i did want to mention that um we
mentioned kind of the lending space as
you can see in this um in this picture
that many of the top projects are
actually lending projects that will lend
uh people um crypto funds the issue is
that currently the most of these lending
projects are basically issuing what are
called fully collateralized loans yeah
so you have to provide some collateral
and then you can take a loan um against
that collateral it very it functions
very much like a mortgage where um
someone can uh take a loan uh uh using
their house as a collateral in some in a
similar way this is how these lending
protocols work one of the
most challenging areas of blockchain
that's kind of that's kind of an
up-and-coming
area for
much more work in the future is
basically the issue of decentralized
uncollateralized loans right so somebody
comes to um to a decentralized
application it says i want to borrow a
certain amount of funds and i have no
collateral to back that up should the
application provide the loan or not
building an application that makes those
decisions correctly is turned out to be
quite difficult
there are a number of projects now that
are trying to uh to do that and um
again i would really encourage you to
kind of take a look at these projects
because this is really one of the
you know cornerstones of uh what still
needs to be done in the space whoever
kind of solves the uncollateralized loan
problem in a good way is is gonna do
quite well um yeah so there are a number
of projects in the space right now what
i did want to mention is why this
problem is so difficult well you know
the problem is how do you make a
decision based on an
address like an ethereum address
is asking for a loan how do you make a
decision whether that loan should be
granted or not more importantly if the
loan if the person taking the loan
defaults on the loan what do we do about
that right so
we need some sort of a global notion of
identity in a sense that if an address
defaults on a loan
something has to be done to prevent who
the owner of that address is just
creating a new address and asking for a
loan again and defaulting defaulting on
that loan again
yeah so there needs to be some sort of a
physical connection to physical
identity that prevents someone from just
coming back over and over and over again
pretending to be someone new every time
and defaulting on those loans that
they're getting and similarly there
needs to be some sort of a legal regime
that if someone defaults on a loan there
are some real world consequences to that
to that default so
in some countries maybe this is doable
and maybe you know maybe in the west
where there are identities
or maybe in developing economies i
should say
where identities and a legal regime is
well developed maybe that's where these
uncollateralized loan systems will will
begin but the goal of course of course
is to make this all
global so anyone in the world can apply
for an uncollateralized loan and the
question is again in an environment
where there is not a strong strong
notion of identity and there isn't a
global regime how do we decide when when
do we approve a loan or not this is
uh to me this is still kind of a hard um
i'd say a hard open problem as i said
there are a number of experiments uh in
in pla in uh in play and it's going to
be really interesting to see um you know
to see who actually controls this market
at the end but this is definitely an
area for for much future research
research and much uh future work
okay
so what i wanted to talk about really is
kind of uh two topics that are sort of
always hot in the area of blockchains
which is scalability
and interoperability interoperability
basically means the means that today we
have multiple blockchains that are sort
of operating in silos and yet the public
would like to be able to interoperate
between those blockchains and the
question is what do we do about that but
let's start with scalability okay so
scalability is a beautiful beautiful
topic uh there's we could do an entire
course just on scalability so uh but
here i only have a few minutes so let me
kind of just zoom in on the part of
scalability that i really enjoy talking
about okay so what is the problem of
course as you know both both for example
bitcoin and ethereum have relatively
slow transaction rate right so bitcoin
can process five to ten transactions a
second ethereum can process 20 to 30
transactions a second what's even more
disturbing is that transaction fees are
actually quite high yeah so in times of
of concentration transaction fees can
actually go up as a up as high as a
hundred dollars for a simple transaction
and this is really harming the ecosystem
right it's really really making it quite
difficult to deploy dapps where
literally every single call to the dap
is gonna cause is gonna cost the caller
uh you know many tens of dollars we'd
like to do something better of course if
you compare this to the visa network the
visa network is much faster
transactions
fees are non-trivial in the visa network
but they don't operate like they do
operate uh in the existing blockchains
so the question is can we do better
right can we scale the blockchain to uh
visa speeds and do so with very low
transaction fees
so there are many beautiful approaches
not a new problem there are many this
has been a question now for many years
and there are many many many beautiful
ideas that have come up um
the first thing that comes to mind is
just you know let's divide let's design
systems that have uh faster consensus
right so maybe the consensus mechanism
itself can handle tens of thousands of
transactions a second and we see
actually modern blockchains that
actually do this i listed a few here but
there are many many others that can
actually scale the consensus mechanism
to tens of thousands of transactions a
second so this is definitely one way to
go but we still love the existing
systems that are out there like ethereum
and you know all the others
can we scale those up
so again in the area of bitcoin one
beautiful idea that has emerged is the
idea of payment channels where in fact
most of the transactions happen
off-chain basically if i want to pay tax
i wouldn't pay pax
through the chain we would just
basically talk to one another uh using a
peer-to-peer method uh the standard way
to do this is using lightning the
lightning system and i hope you you're
following recent news but actually the
news out of sri lanka is really quite
interesting in that in sri lanka they
decided to make bitcoin
legal tender um i would assume that in
the future they'll make other coins
legal tender as well but right now
bitcoin is considered uh or is about to
become legal tender in sri lanka but if
you're going to run a national economy
on top of bitcoin you have to scale up
the system and lightning is sort of the
the way to scale it up um
you know there are wallets bitcoin
wallets that natively supports
payment channels through lightning the
strike wallet as an example and those
are going to be used and those are
likely to be used quite heavily in sri
lanka and in fact you've probably been
if you're following the news you're
probably seeing that um the lightning
network is getting considerably more use
now than it did before what is it
they're up to uh 25 000 nodes at this
point which is
remarkable yeah which is wonderful to
see this taking off um and again if
you're going to build a national economy
with bitcoin as a legal tender you have
to do something like payment channels so
it's not too surprising that lightning
is is taking off and i expect that um
you know if this experiments sri lanka
succeeds and maybe expands to other
countries i would expect um payment
channels to uh to even grow further in
size so then moving on to uh to the more
programmable blockchains the other
approaches are the layer two approaches
things like roll up optimistic rollup
where the idea is to batch many
transactions into a single transaction
and actually this is what i want to
focus on yeah so for the next few
minutes i'm going to talk about roll-up
approaches just because they're so
pretty and i really love describing them
um
and then of course there are many other
ideas that have been out there like
scaling is such a hot topic such a
important topic that there are many many
experiments taking place but let's zoom
in and talk a little bit about the
roll-up approaches and how they work
okay
so there are kind of fundamentally two
roll-up uh techniques one is called zk
and what is one is called optimistic
i'm going to focus mostly on the zk one
but most of what i say is going to apply
to the optimistic methods as well okay
so
what is the idea behind row up
i wish i could kind of ask the audience
like how many of you are familiar with
roll up and how many would like me to go
into the into the into to give an
overview but so i'll take a middle
ground i'll kind of ex i'll quickly
explain what roll-up is and then we'll
get to the more interesting parts of
roll-up um all right so so today
basically when you post a transaction
to or a you know a block of transactions
to the blockchain today um the way the
system works is fairly inefficient yeah
if we have you know a number of you know
hundreds of miners or maybe thousands of
miners running the system
all of them have to verify all the
transactions in the block yeah so one
miner gets to mint a block containing
many transactions and then everybody in
the ecosystem has to go and verify that
the block is valid so there's a lot of
repeated work that's taking place today
and obviously that's um wasted effort
it'd be nice if just one person can
validate and everybody else can just
prove very verify that they did their
job correctly and that's kind of the
idea behind roll up what we're going to
do is we're going to introduce what's
called a roll up coordinator and instead
of people sending their transactions
directly to the blockchain what they'll
do is they'll send their transactions to
the rollup coordinator the roll-up
coordinator what it will do is it will
batch all these transactions into a
single
roll-up update block very short roll-up
update block but more importantly the
roll-up coordinator is the one that's
going to verify all the transactions you
know that everything is properly signed
and the account balances are correct and
so on
so it does all the heavy work of
verifying the transactions and then it's
going to produce a very short proof
that all these transactions are valid
yeah and this is kind of where the magic
is uh this is done using using something
called a snark it's a sync
non-interactive argument
which allows you to very
efficiently or rather create a very
short proof
that all the transactions are valid and
verifying that proof is also very very
simple right so literally you can take
thousands of transactions compress them
into a a single commitment and provide a
proof that that
commitment represents a valid set of
transactions and anyone can very easily
verify that those transactions are all
correct so we send this proof to the
blockchain
along with a summary of all the
transactions we'll see why we have to
send a summary in just a minute
and then now what the validators do or
what the miners do is rather than verify
the transactions themselves all they do
is they verify the proof
and again as i said verifying the proof
is much much much easier than verifying
the transactions by the way this also
saves a lot of space on the blockchain
because this transaction summary doesn't
include any of the digital signatures
and in fact digital signatures are a big
chunk of transaction data
all that can be removed and what
actually gets stored in the blockchain
is just a proof and just a summary of
the transactions without the digital
signatures so not only are we reducing
work for the verifiers we're also saving
a lot of space on the blockchain by
doing this okay so that's the idea of
roll up and again there's two ways to do
it in the result in the zk roll up
basically the mind the roller the
coordinator provides a proof the
transactions are valid in the optimistic
roll up there is no proof and instead uh
there's a mechanism by which uh by which
anyone can complain
that um that uh an update message from
the coordinator was uh invalid and then
things can get rolled back yeah so those
are two different methods for uh role um
for doing this uh batch batch processing
of transactions but at a high level the
idea is to just batch a lot of
transactions um using the coordinator
so i'm going to focus on the zk version
just because i love these these snark
proofs a lot of our research
is focused on snark proofs and so i'm
going to talk a little bit more about
how they work okay so yeah as i say here
basically the coordinator is compressing
thousands of transactions into a single
on-chain proof which just everyone
verifies
okay so just to kind of explain in a bit
more detail how this works uh let me
kind of let's walk through an example so
here we have the coordinator the
coordinator is managing
accounts for many many different users
and every user has a balance which the
coordinator actually knows all right so
that's kind of the setup everybody the
coordinator knows exactly who the users
are what their balances are the
coordinator is going to create a merkle
root of all these account balances if
you don't need if you don't know what a
merkle tree is don't worry about it it's
not important what it's what's important
to know is this is just a way to commit
to to uh the current state of all the
accounts okay so the coordinator creates
sort of a very short commitment to the
states of all the accounts and it pushes
that uh that commitment that roots it's
a very short route just 32 bytes that
gets pushed onto the layer one
blockchain
all right so we write to a particular
block uh just 32 bytes and that already
commits the coordinator to the entire
view of this layer two network
okay the next thing that happens is uh
users want to transact so we have our
friends here and say alice says i want
to send to eth to bob and here is my
signature to say that i'm approving this
transaction yeah
bob says i want to do an atomic swap
with zoe right so i want to send one
easter zoe and she's going to send me uh
two bats back yeah and here's the signal
here is my signature on this transaction
and here's zoe's signature on this
transaction right so this is a way to
execute an atomic swap on the using the
coordinator using a rollup and then you
know whoever let's say this is carol she
submits her transaction as well so
everybody submits their transaction to
transactions to the coordinator what the
coordinator does is it checks that all
the signatures are valid
then it goes ahead and updates
everybody's account balances okay so you
see alice paid bob to eth and um so
let's see so alice's eth uh count should
go down to only one youth right and so
the coordinator updates everybody's
balances you can see alice now only has
one eth and everybody else's balances
were updated as well
the coordinator now computes the
numerical roots of the current state of
the world this can be done actually
fairly efficiently all right so we can
compute a new commitment to everybody's
balances and then the coordinator pushes
this new commitment onto the blockchain
along with the transaction data
transaction summary and along with the
proof that the transition from the hash
uh sorry the hash and block 354 to the
hash and block 357 that transition was
valid all right so what does snark proof
is actually proving is it is that the
transition from uh the old merkle tree
to the numerical tree is
proper and done right so everybody's
transactions were signed everybody had
enough balances in their account to
support their transaction and so on so
this is how um we move from one state of
the world to the next state of the world
by simply pushing a very short
commitment to the blockchain right so
the 32 byte commitment in block for 354
32 byte commitment in block 357 and
we're committing to millions of accounts
here yeah that's kind of the amazing
thing and the transition the blockchain
the layer one blockchain can verify that
the transaction is valid
simply by checking this very short proof
yeah and the amazing thing this really
is mind-blowing is that uh you can
verify that the transition is correct
even though there are thousands of
transactions in this transition you can
verify that the transition is correct
simply by verifying a very simple smart
proof yeah and that takes constant work
uh so very little work for the miners to
actually verify the transition is
correct so a we save space in the
blockchain and b we save a lot of work
for the miners because they just they
just verify a simple proof they don't
actually verify the the batch of
transactions okay so that's the idea
behind behind zk roll up and now there's
a lot of interesting details yeah so
let's talk a little bit about the
details so first of all you see that uh
transactions within a single rollup
system basically if alice wants to pay
bob and both of them are on the same
rollup system
that's actually really easy that's
exactly what rollup is designed to do
and settlement to this transaction is
done on the l1 network right as soon as
the rollup the coordinator pushes the
state update to the l1 network the
transaction is done very fast very
simple uh settlement of transactions now
you could imagine there will be multiple
roll up systems out there in fact we
already have
multiple roll up systems deployed and so
if one roll-up system suppose i have an
account on one roll-up system and my
friend has an account in a different
roll-up system how do how do i pay my
friend
naive way to do it is basically to have
me move my funds to ethereum so out of
the roll-up system onto the layer one
network and then from ethereum i would
move the funds to my friend's roll-up
system yeah so i have to go in sort of a
v
direction where i have to move from l2
to l1 and then from l1 to l2 as i say in
the second bullet here moving funds from
a roll-up system back onto ethereum back
onto the l1 is actually much more
expensive because this is not handled
within the batch in fact now the
coordinator has to issue an ethereum
transaction that moves funds from the
coordinator's account into my account
okay so this is actually much more
expensive than simple roll up to roll up
roll up to l1 requires
additional work on the l1 network so we
get higher transaction fees as a result
so again going back to the case where i
wanted to move funds from one roll-up
system to a different roll-up system if
i did this through the layer one network
that would be quite expensive
and so what's interesting is there's
actually a lot of work now on how do we
actually transition funds directly from
one layer two network to another layer
two network without actually touching
the layer one network yeah and that's
actually done through uh through
bridging mechanisms which we'll talk
about a little bit later but the whole
intraoperability question it's really
interesting that typically when we think
of interoperability we think about inter
interoperability between say ethereum
and bitcoin or ethereum polka dot like
interoperability between layer one
networks but there's also um very
interesting question around interrupt
interoperability between layer two
networks and again there are projects
that are specifically uh designed to
address um you know layer two to layer
two transfers
okay so that's one issue basically
transferring assets um uh you know
within roll-up systems or in among the
role or inside a roll-up system and so
on
another issue
is basically how do we migrate projects
from a layer one network like ethereum
to run on uh a layer two layer two
roll-up systems so one very interesting
and exciting development that's like
about to be deployed is what's called a
zk evm yeah zero knowledge evm uh one
example is the one developed by matter
labs but other other companies are
working on this as well so the vke vm to
me honestly
is a surprise right this is something
that um kind of we thought would be very
difficult and would take many many many
years to develop something that actually
works well you know what the community
showed is that in fact uh running zero
knowledge proof proofs on an entire
solidity contract actually is doable and
in fact quite practical yeah so what a
zkevm does is basically provides
absolutely compatibility to the picture
that we just showed right so the picture
we showed basically showed very simple
transactions between members of um of a
roll-up system
but
more generally we'd like to run solidity
programs right we'd like to run daps on
top of the
on top of a coordinator which would mean
that the coordinator now has to produce
proofs
that a solidity program ran correctly
and how do you prove
that uh how do you prove that the
execution path at the complete execution
path of an entire solidity slowly
program that is actually seemed quite
difficult but in fact now is getting not
only is it getting deployed it seems
actually quite practical and ready for
use so this is a pretty exciting
development i think for um zk roll up
systems so we're going to see this in a
lot of different zk roll up systems not
just matter labs i think they're going
to be a number of them that deploy these
kind of systems and the beauty of this
is it makes it actually quite easy to
migrate applications
from um that are currently running on
ethereum to basically run on top of a
rollup and as a result the layer one
system theorem for example ethereum
would primarily be responsible for
settlements so that
mostly most of the work that they would
do would just be verifying um uh snark
proofs and keeping track of the root
commitment that the roll-up system uh
sends on to the to the ethereum network
yeah so this is this is a pretty
exciting development would allow us to
run dapps on layer two at a much lower
rate with a much lower transaction fee
rate what i would say though again just
to be
complete i would say that uh the
optimistic methods
optimistic grow up actually already
supports compatibility with the evm so
migrating from the level one ethereum to
uh to the layer two optimistic roll up
is already quite easy
um yeah and so we already have that so
why do we need uh what do we need a
zkevm and the answer is that uh
transaction finality is a little bit or
rather uh um the speed of which at which
finality happens is a little bit easier
with um with with these proofs right as
soon as you verify the proof
the transactions are basically basically
finalized uh yeah so there's interesting
developments in this space and that's
kind of where we are so i hope this was
clear it's kind of to me this is like an
amazing development that's happening in
the space just to see this being
deployed the fact that
zk evms are possible is remarkable and
i'm really happy to see this actually
getting used
the last thing i want to talk about
rollups is uh
the the fear of centralization
yeah so
you should be asking yourself well what
did we just do here so this coordinator
sounds like it's a centralized central
uh entity it's a single point of failure
and so there it naively might introduce
some centralization fears but the answer
is that no the roll-up server is
actually not that sorry the coordinator
is not actually
a point a single point of failure in
fact if the coordinator fails let's say
it just dies and stops working it's not
the end of the world the idea would be
that the users will simply find a
different coordinator that's able to
produce proofs and push them onto the
network yeah so it's actually it
certainly can't cheat because the
coordinator can't cheat
cannot cheat because it can't produce
proofs if it tries to do invalid
transactions and if it even if it dies
it's not the end of the world users can
simply use a different coordinator that
will produce proofs there's one wrinkle
which is if the coordinator
dies and we need to we need to start a
new coordinator somehow this new
coordinator needs to get all the account
information current account information
in order to be able to produce proofs
and the question is how do we get the
current account information if the
coordinator we're currently using is
dead and no longer responds
and so there are two solutions to this
i'm going to use the name that matter
labs use use here but there are many
names to these and different systems
i'll give these solutions different
names i'm just going to call them zeke
async and zk porter these are two
different solutions for enabling a new
coordinator to uh come in if the
existing coordinator stops working yeah
and both of these work concurrently um
so what is zk sync and zk porter so the
idea in zk sync is basically what we saw
so far where basically all the
transaction data so a summary of all the
transactions is stored on the ethereum
network right so the layer one chain
basically will accept a batch of
transaction transactions only if that
batch contains
uh transaction summaries and those
transaction summaries are consistent
with the proof that it was submitted to
the back to the to the uh layer one
network okay so basically since all
transaction data now is stored on the
layer one network on ethereum the new
coordinator can simply run through all
these transactions construct the latest
states and take over from the old
coordinator
so that works perfectly fine and in fact
that's traditionally what's called a
roll-up system
the only problem is this introduces
higher ethereum transaction fees because
we're storing all this transaction data
on the ethereum network itself yeah so
even though it's stored as call data
there are still fees associated with
storing this data on the ethereum
network so zk porter is basically
another idea which is a way to reduce
those transaction fees and the idea is
basically basically to introduce a
secondary blockchain yeah this is a
a proof of stake style blockchains where
um where all this transaction data will
be stored on the secondary blockchain
yeah and again the l1 network will
accept transaction only if um
only if the secondary blockchain says
that it has all the transaction data
okay so again this is as i said
maintained by staked coordinator we now
have cheap off chain storage right which
is stored somewhere else by these um by
these other backup systems backup
servers and then um if again if the
coordinator that we're using dies we can
simply go to this other blockchain
recover all the transaction data
reconstruct the current states and start
a new coordinator uh to get it to do
whatever whatever we need to do
uh okay so basically uh you know this is
what provides cheap off store off
storage uh off chain storage it doesn't
have the same guarantees as ek sync
because the data is not actually on
ethereum but the beauty of this is that
it's up to the user to decide how do you
want the account managed do you want the
accounts managed on zk sync where you
have stronger guarantees but higher fees
or do you want it on zk porter where you
have much lower fees but now you have to
trust these other coordinators to make
sure that they maintain all transaction
data so it's up to the user to decide
how to do this which is kind of which is
kind of cool
all right so this is all i wanted to say
about
roll up i'll just say that it's an
amazing application of cryptographic
proof systems one might wonder about
privacy because as i described the
system today the coordinator sees all
the transactions in the clear so there's
a question of whether we can actually
hide transactions for the coordinator
and it turns out using again clever zero
knowledge techniques something called
zkzq roll up it turns out it's not that
hard to hide transactions from the
coordinator so we can even build this
whole system and provide
privacy uh you know potentially a
compliant privacy to uh to to end users
yeah and there's lots of research
including the research in my own group
on making these proof systems uh as
best as uh you know as best as possible
for uh for a roll up like like system
okay so this is all i wanted to say
about roll up uh sorry i really like
talking about this this is such a
beautiful idea that i really enjoy
describing how it works i did want to
talk about interoperability but i see
that we're running a little bit low on
time so i did want to leave a few
minutes for four questions so
in the interest of leaving time for
questions
maybe um
maybe i'll just say that
interoperability is primarily done
through bridges by building
uh
you know proper bridges uh maybe i'll
just mention that uh here let's see if i
can
jump no i can't jump so i'll just run
through what i had to say here
um this will all be covered in the in
the class so if any of you want to
listen here this you can you're very
welcome to join the class i'll just say
that um when it comes to
interoperability
uh one design that seems to be
quite promising is it this is a star
design star network where we have you
know all the wonderful blockchains that
have been developed and then there is a
network being formed called the axler
network that actually allows any smart
contract on any one of these chains so
in this ethereum smart contract can make
a call to say to the uh solana
smart
smart contract on solana the smart
contract can respond um you can even
chain calls and all that is done through
the xlr network it's kind of an elegant
design in how this works and so
hopefully uh this intro interoperability
problem um will be solved too by you
know correct use of of bridges and
bridging networks like this
but sadly i'm out of time so i think
i'll
touch on one last topic and then i'll
stop
so
uh yeah so in terms of final thoughts
you know there's a lot of discussion
right now on
about central bank digital currencies
and particularly i'm sure all of you are
aware that china is kind of leading the
role here they deployed they sell
themselves deployed a central bank
digital currency this is not what we
would call a blockchain it's not what we
would call we would call a
cryptocurrency it's basically
more of a centralized system where the
central bank holds everybody's accounts
and people transact
on those accounts so of course with that
design there are concerns about privacy
that you know central the central bank
sees a lot of transactions uh questions
of interoperability with um other
central banks who might want to deploy a
central bank digital currency questions
about censorship questions about world
world power and so on so in fact there's
a um we at stanford are putting a very
large report on the chinese cbdc so it
was very interesting to kind of deep
deep dive deeply into what's being built
there and what are the global
implications of this i hope the report
will be ready in about a month and so i
encourage you uh to read it it'll be
very detailed and um
go into a lot of the
technical and and political questions
around this system
the one thing that i wanted to talk
about is you know what should countries
in the west do in particular what should
the u.s central banks do bank do should
it also provide its own digital currency
and again people have lots of different
stuff different opinions about this my
personal opinion is that this is kind of
not how things work in the u.s in the
sense that in the u.s we let private
industry drive technology and the
government's role is more and just to
make sure
no harm is being done ideally
and and so there are actually lots of
companies in the blockchain ecosystem
who can
without too much work step up and
provide
the technical capabilities for build for
building something like a u.s
central bank digital currency and so the
hope is that uh by working with uh the
blockchain ecosystem and actually with
the community at large
we um we can do something similar in the
us so i think i'll stop here
uh and i'm very very happy to take any
questions any but anybody have so thank
you so much for uh speaking around and i
look forward to seeing you in one of
these future events
and yeah now we can turn it on to uh q a
so
hand it over to you oh
great thank you and that was that was uh
amazing um i thought maybe it might be
worth staying a little bit longer and
starting with questions on the on the
roll-ups because you you spent some time
on that uh i i think you addressed it in
your issue but if you could just go over
in your discussion if you could go over
in a little bit more detail
how there was some confusion about how a
rollup wasn't a new centralized system
do you need to trust the person who or
the entity that's
doing the roll-up or how is it distinct
from the centralized system
yeah yeah no i think that's a that's a
wonderful question so in some sense
we're sending our transactions to the
coordinator the coordinator then uh one
might worry that the coordinator is a
centralized party so first of all it's
very important to understand that the
coordinator
is not trusted in a sense that it cannot
cheat right it will only be able to
issue an acceptable proof
if all the transactions that received
are properly signed and all of them are
valid transactions
yeah so it simply cannot create a fake
proof that's because of the security of
the proof system and so it can't it it
can't cheat but what it can do is for
example refuse to accept transactions
from somebody right or you could go
offline altogether
the interesting thing there is that
there's no no reason why there's only
one coordinator you could have multiple
coordinators as long as they all see
agree on the
on the current state of the world
basically that you can send your
transactions to any coordinator that
you'd like and if any one of the
coordinators accepts your transactions
then uh the transaction will get posted
will get included in a batch of
transactions which will then get posted
onto the blockchain yeah so
uh the yeah so the we don't need to
worry so much about uh cheating because
that's not possible and in terms of
censorship or or just denial of service
the the the reason this works is because
these systems are designed to have
multiple coordinators active at any
given time and this is exactly why it
was so important to have transaction
data available to all these coordinators
and i mentioned two different ways to
store the transaction data either on
chain or off chain and both of those
have under consequences to both right
transact higher transaction fees for one
but higher guarantees uh with those
higher transaction fees yeah it's a
great question thank you for asking
i think maybe we could stick with a few
higher level given time um and so
one question that maybe is is uh related
to that is can you comment on the
relationship you mentioned denial
service attacks on on on the on the um
on the coordinator can you comment a
little bit more on the relationship
between cryptocurrencies and the
availability and integrity of the
network infrastructure more generally
what is there what is the relationship
between those two
uh in the network you mean that
so the question is about the i guess the
decentralized network infrastructure yes
we're sort of asking about security of
the consensus layer that's really where
where the question is is headed and
again the consensus layer is designed to
operate as long as you know 51 of the
participants are honest so if there's a
network partition
right that because of a network attack
or an outage then yeah then there are
there are there are issues right the
network will have trouble accepting
accepting new transactions um
uh yeah so
there well what can i say i mean so
the um
the security of the system just depends
on decent decentralization there's no no
doubt there right we need to have 51
honest parties uh there's actually a
fair amount of work even at the
networking layer to make sure that
miners are properly connected and that
they're connected over sufficiently fast
links
so you have to remember this is the
these systems have only been around for
a decade and already seeing the amount
of infrastructure that's being built to
support these systems is truly
remarkable right so the fact that there
are now um
um you know there there are uh
additional networks that are being built
just to provide connectivity between
miners
you know these are overlay networks yeah
it's it's wonderful to see right so it
all guarantees um it all goes basically
back to guaranteeing that the network
remains up one thing that i do that i
should say
is
in some sense because of the consensus
protocols that are needed for
decentralization
um not by design but because of these
consensus protocols these blockchain
systems have an extremely high uptime
yeah um
compared to like just traditional cloud
services that have outrages from time to
time we see that these uh the blockchain
networks generally you know they're
they're very reliable uh just you know
as long because as long as enough miners
are up the system works and so
you know um we get reliability actually
almost as a consequence of the consensus
protocols that we have so yeah that's i
think that's all i'll say about that so
thanks for the question
that's right and and maybe that you've
already covered this but related to to
what you were just mentioning is how
common is a 51
attack or is that something that people
anticipate and how
how do what do you do in response to
that so is this a situation where you
don't have 51 of the miners who are
honest
yeah
so that's a great question i guess we've
already seen some examples of 51 attacks
on these on these any smaller networks
at least uh yeah so look it can't that's
an assumption that's an assumption that
builds that's built
into the system
um i think the the the
the good news is that there are proper
incentives in place to make sure
these systems continue to operate
correctly right so the miners
either they invested heavily in hardware
or they're going to be staked heavily in
a proof of stake system or they invested
heavily in disks in a proof of space
system like chia
so that that they already the miners
themselves are quite heavily
incentivized to make sure the system
operates correctly and really if you
think about it at the end of the at the
end of the day you know
security and proper operation of a
system often is tied back to incentives
and here the good news you know
because the incentives were set up
properly it's it we see this that
somebody could come close we could come
close to a 51 attack and then people
back away from it because they don't
want that they don't want to harm the
overall operation of the system so
um and yeah and that's why this works
just the incentives are are aligned with
everyone making sure the system works
correctly
i think we're just about a time so dan
maybe one last question um that's come
up a couple times is just the
you know the relationship between
blockchain and sort of environmental
concerns and energy use has there been
any work in that space do you have any
thoughts on that
a lot of work yes so right right right
so i guess this comes up all the time
too
you have to remember that uh bitcoin was
the very first blockchain that came out
and that used proof of work which is not
environmentally friendly
um ethereum came came after also used
proof of work which uh has also
which is not environmentally friendly
the good news is that we know what to do
right the new new blockchains that were
that are being developed
are primarily based are much more
environmentally friendly right they're
based on proof of stake they're based on
proof of space
ethereum already announced plans to move
to a proof of stake system
and so it's quite interesting that
moving forward
most of the the common blockchains are
going to be proof of stake which is not
that which does simply doesn't have
environmental concerns
for bitcoin it's actually quite
interesting this is this is kind of a
challenge for the future i think in that
we might end up in a world where the
majority of blockchains are
environmentally friendly either proof of
stake or proof of space but the bitcoin
like systems
which are probably not going to be
changing right those one of the nice
things about bitcoin is you know you
know what it is and it's going to be
like that for a while uh that's probably
going to keep on going being a proof of
work
um and so
you can think for yourself what are the
implications where we have an ecosystem
that is environmentally friendly with
one blockchain not being environment
environmentally friendly it's kind of
interesting
to uh to think about what would happen
in that environment but it sounds like
that's actually where things are where
things are headed
it's a good question
and uh
but the good news is there is a the
community is aware of this there's a
very good answer that's where things are
going so things will be much more
environment and more environmentally
friendly moving moving forward
thank you so much for your time then i
know we ran a little bit over and thank
you everyone for joining us that was
wonderful we didn't get to all the
questions
but we appreciate you participating so
thank you everyone
this is great thank you all
you